do you want no one leaves 90 troll and
everybody wants dijo the teachers were
like I'm gonna die Salaam alaikum peace
be unto you you're watching the Dean
show we're here every week same time
same channel and if you don't see us on
the TV you can watch all of our shows at
the Dean show calm you can also go there
to see more speakers that we've had in
the past but today the wonderful speaker
our guest dr. Mann do is going to be
talking about the key the key to what
your car to your garage to your house no
the key to paradise when we come back
here on the deanship love there's only
one word am helmet is his messenger
Allah that you love
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger Allah no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice Salaam
alaikum Salam o like what I got peace be
unto you and to you as well I'm getting
very comfortable working with you time
to let me too we done some shows and the
past and people can go to the Dean show
you got your own section there honey let
me unlike sent me a lot except this from
all of us now I mean there's a key yeah
and that key fits into somewhere so we
want to talk about this key it's not to
someone's house car it's the key to
paradise yeah let's talk about this [ __ ]
please when we talk about the key to
paradise we really don't talk about the
real keen with we talk about a metaphor
here that the any key that has some
teeth in it without these teeth it
wouldn't open and here we're talking
about opening the key that will opening
the door of paradise and the gauge
progress on the top of that is knowledge
seeking knowledge so the first key is
seeking knowledge having knowledge
because if you don't have knowledge
about something you become ignorant you
don't know what's going on so seeking
knowledge and that's why seek knowledge
is an obligation upon every male or
female Muslim and in fact it is an
obligation on everyone because if you
can afford it yes you can do it so with
knowledge you would know what you're
doing you would know what a las 10 dolla
wants from you without knowledge what
can you do a for example let me give you
an example can you build a car without
knowledge about mechanics without
knowledge about electricity without no
you cannot not takes enough for it takes
some effort you need you need the
knowledge before you start practicing
yeah so seeking knowledge is very
important knowing the things especially
this religion
is all of it is based on knowledge
fallom and now lalla lalla a lot of the
hospital is telling Muhammad SAW Salem
you should know that there is no God
except Almighty Allah so seeking
knowledge and is the first teeth to that
we say among these qualities that are in
the key that would help you open
paradise so the first tooth is seeking
knowledge and the second what did what
should you know first person in this
life what does he need to know first
there's a lot of things that are going
on in the world frees up let me tell you
that the amount of knowledge that were
brought up to humanity in year two
thousand seven equals the amount of
knowledge that was on the earth for the
last 5,000 years knowledge a lot of
information a lot of data a lot of
knowledge are there and we need to know
so which which type of knowledge that I
need to know because there's a lot and
you have to pick up choose now there
should be priorities and this is done in
the first message that was given to
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon the first
lezzie was given to him was read recite
know about what bismillah pic about your
Lord so now it's a step here it's not
appear achieving the PhD first that can
become second third or fourth second it
with it it yes but the main priorities
you should know about you've create all
about the one who gave your life yes and
he'll give you death absolutely when the
prophet mohamed salah salem there was a
case that a shepherd hit his maid or
servant who was looking after his sheep
and the prophets allah Selim called her
and asked her about the first thing the
first question that the prophets allah
salam asked her was where is Allah so he
asked her are not a question of
knowledge so she said she pointed to
this guy and the prophets allah salem
from this answer knew knew that she is a
muslimah yes and he asked a person to
set her free yeah so what I'm saying
here portlets of knowledge here because
you could not be
any person who has value in this life
without knowledge why why is it
difficult for a lot of people you'll see
them acquire even sit through the
toughest math classes the toughest
calculus class and they'll study so hard
because they have a vision they have a
vision they're going to get this degree
and then they're going to get this
status but when it comes to getting a
person a book to read about something
that should be the most important thing
who their Creator is absolutely and what
he wants from him this is like
kryptonite to some thank you you know
kryptonite Superman yeah makes the
strongest man week they just find it so
difficult why yes simply because i would
say that their vision is very limited
vision they don't have this broad vision
yeah that if even the vision that we
muslims have is given to us by Almighty
Allah he said that directly vision to
the maximum goal the maximum world is
what for anyone is paradise reaching
paradise in order to enjoy all the type
of info enjoyment that a Lost Planet
Allah will provide us in order to see a
Lost Planet I'll in order to live with
forever not suffering from any type of
disease or any type of calamity we want
this type of life they're not seeing
that they are not seeing that they're
just a just limited to a PG or
evaluation or working in a big job and
being a rich person or something we're
making some achievements in the world
yes which is not bad but it is still a
limited versus you know a person with
this big whole picture that a Muslim
targets and I think any one of them is
is subject to training and I mean we can
train when they know the truth they
start changing so the Prophet a la scala
directed Mohamed Salah salon mind
directed all of us is that your first
priority in this life is your Lord your
Creator you should know the one who gave
you everything that you have you have a
brain you got to be HD because of your
brain it's because who gave you this
brain it's all white a lie you didn't
make your print you just used it
correctly right and there's if you used
it correctly there is another way of
using using it better the way to use it
better is to know about the one who gave
you this prank in order to thank him
right in order to tell him that yes I am
grateful to you because you endowed me
with all these good qualities that I use
them in this life without them I cannot
live without them I could not compete so
that key that we put there he is the
first tooth of it is knowledge seek
knowledge and this knowledge should be
linked it with the most important
knowledge which is the a las 10 dolla
knowing about a lot that's why the
second thing after seeking knowledge
knowledge of la illaha illallah Mohammad
Rasool let's let's elaborate on this yes
sir so there's something here of a
negation a gate of something personally
a Muslim would say but before he said
that Allah is the only Lord he would say
he would negate all the gods that are
claimed to be gods he would negate that
and say that there is no true God
because there are many goods for example
in India there 360 million idols people
worship them yeah they think they are
not so everywhere in the world you find
people think that that the art God's
this is god this is god this is gone so
before you say Allah you shouldna get
that there is not a single other God
accept almighty so some examples if you
are living during the time now of
another messenger say Jesus piece behind
and NSA they were worshiping you know a
jupiter venus the Greeks and the Romans
they had all these different gods those
were negation they're not really today
we don't have those gods let's say
someone doesn't visualize that give us a
practical example how money your status
java can people think that you talk
about it yes for example people they're
all ideas their own whims people love
themselves so much degree that they
think that they are gods and the Quran
said something about that said our item
n da da Allahu hawa have you seen the
person who have seen his desires who
have taken his desire as his own God
that means that he's following his
desires as well as like what I think my
opinion is that my opinion is better
than her Danya so forget about what God
or my
me eyes with LEDs find a lot of how you
made yourself a god absolutely i want it
i did that yeah we did that they are
making himself stuff something about
above other human being yeah this is of
course one of the diseases that people
have eleni to refocus their attention to
rethink of the passage that they are
going through with that let's take a
break shake and we'll be back here God
willing on the d shows Echols no speech
is better than to do that would call
people to Allah and to do there were no
speeches better no nothing is better
than that is it true that if one person
I'm the Allah giving you an ability to
guide someone for the lost permission
the creator's permission that was better
than everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be giving out
getting down and this is something that
we encourage all the msas all the dowel
organizations the muskegs forget this we
want to treat more we give these to the
non-muslims for free for free for free
one-hour brothers age I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone if a las bombas I i am not afraid
to stand alone i am not afraid to stand
alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if a las vacas I i
am not afraid to stay
welcome back to the Dean shall we are
discussing the key to paradise we left
off with knowledge and now we're coming
to the negation negating any other deal
God and you left off with desires you
making yourself into a gantry shop or
other or other examples that people
loved money so much or people love other
desires so much these are types of and
people still love on worship idols in
different places so then this issue is
very important knowledge about God now
we're talking about God except who is
here a las panel time when we say this
we need to focus on two issues the most
important things that's to guarantee and
ensure that the knowledge that you get
about God is correct because if this
knowledge is not correct it will lead to
deviant thinking that just makes sense
you want to write a biography about
someone make sure exactly because if you
misunderstand any quality of him this
will lead you to other things gotcha
yeah for example of misunderstandings
that's when people say that God has a
sap which is according to the Quran
according to our believe we're according
to any rational that it's the biggest
insult that you make to God when you say
that the reason is give us the reason
about so can we bring it home absolute
many people are having this belief the
reason is you down great almighty allah
from the developer level to the human
level because this is a quality of
creature now a quality of humans to have
chance and animals to write animals and
all the creatures yeah but it is not the
quality of the creation it's not the
quality of the creator of this creation
a las planet Allah is unique is
different from that so when you insult
him by saying that he has a son this is
the biggest insult yeah and the reason
is that you don't grade him yeah and the
Quran has many verses about that you're
making him similar to his creature and
there's nothing similar to the graphic
similarities to all my tailor nothing is
equal to him nothing is like him yeah
yeah so knowledge that's why it's our
knowledge you have to be sure that it is
authentic one hundred percent otherwise
it it affects the brain and that's why
you find many people learn if not all
the people who became Muslims to where
Christians for example they would say
that we never truly believe that God has
a son because it just doesn't make sense
yeah it doesn't make sense yeah it
doesn't and then this this they found
the answer in the Quran almost in every
yes because we when we think about it we
think okay you know catch have kittens
dogs had puppies cows have cash what
word of God have baby girls baby God
doesn't makes a big at and Andrew said
it what does he look like and he becomes
in a form of a man now you gotta
described describe God color was he
because if you say that the Sun is like
this so you imagine that he looks like
his what so now you given a visual
you're giving him something visual
limitless power Allah is beyond it you
limit when you say that that he has a
son or you give him any quality that a
human beings have anyone now I think you
know what the light bulbs coming on if
there's a seam Delilah so now this is an
important issue seeking the knowledge
about good which is correct and
authentic knowledge the second one is
the more you get knowledge about the law
the more you live soundly and safely in
this earth yes because you would know
that he loves you he is so merciful to
you he is the all knowing he is the old
powerful you know all these aspects of
Almighty Allah so you start knowing him
and this knowing and this knowledge
about Allah leads to love you cannot
love something that you are not aware of
if I ask you this question do you love
rambutan and nanka leave your love you
can see it in your face this is a what
are you talking about these are
beautiful fruits yeah but you don't know
them because you don't have you didn't
have any experience with him they are
very beautiful fruits that the dro in
Southeast Asia and because you don't
know that you cannot develop this
relationship with them but I know them
so i know i love Darcy would simply
because I know them so when you know
about a los portales start developing
this attitude of loving Almighty Allah
based on the knowledge that you get on
him so how do we get the knowledge that
so we set a negation okay so we want to
know that we're negating anything that
was in the creation was born God isn't
here living with us died that was not
God can ever be quickly so God is one
who created everything food that is the
first part right yeah let's move on to
the second okay the second part that
Muhammad is His Messenger okay is that
same as like if you were living during
the time of Jesus he was absolutely this
is moses was the message i'm coming to
that okay the message at the time of
Jesus was la la la la and Jesus is the
message saying what you just said
negation affirmation of course because
getting all false gods it's impossible
that Jesus would give a different
message than Moses then then Abraham
then Muhammad I makes total sense
messengers it doesn't make sense what
makes sense that all those messengers
brought the same message from Almighty
Allah to the people yeah so now yeah and
the reason is you have to witness that
because the information about God that
we got we got through Mohammed or at the
time of Jesus the the people there got
it through Jesus at the time of Moses
they got it through Moses so there
should be this is the second part of it
there is no god but Allah and Muhammad
is His Messenger so because Muhammad is
the one who brought us the knowledge
about God he brought us the Quran yeah
and the Quran is the main source of
knowledge about God just like Jesus if
you can library on this he brought
revelation which was the bayou nine
Geale the NGO and then moses but the
Torah the Torah absolute so you had to
go through there Matt like Nestle music
premise into sir but to their teachings
true i think people get this confused
yeah because i betray to ask people
absolutely because the revelation came
to Jesus and the revelation came to
Moses and the revelation came to
Muhammad sallallahu Salem so they know
about Allah subhanAllah
and the teachers of alcalá and the last
palette Alec guaranteed that the
knowledge that Jesus had that Moses had
and Muhammad had all this is correct
knowledge but if someone says you know
what look I love Jesus so much I'm just
going to not worship him but I'm going
to follow his teaching and they forget
about the last and final measure problem
on those people most of them because
they didn't know about aha yeah so
that's why they think that they need to
yes for example the people at the time
of Moses right they followed the
footsteps of Moses and these would step
stopped when Jesus came because this
game so this had cancelled I wouldn't
say cancel but at least this revived
that so they should follow the people
who were living will fall or following
Moses and Moses died at the time of
Jesus they have to follow Jesus yeah
right cuz they witness that that's it
the people who were living at the time
of Jesus let me assume that some person
who was living at the time of Jesus and
then after that Jesus was taken to
heaven as we believe Muslims and that so
he disappeared and after that the
message of mohamed salah salem cape we
are obliged to follow the message of
muhammad but the problem is a lot of
people don't know this issue don't know
that mohamed salah salem is the final
messenger and we tell the people were
have you ever heard about another
messenger after Muhammad all those
people who claim that they are messenger
any average person would be able to
discover that you can they artificially
a lie of course their credibility it's a
let us look into absolute into their
history yeah you saw something amazing
the more before when we spoke the more
you look into this man's life yes its
ear Lee I've been looking for trouble
yeah what if you're looking to spin
something trouble you're fine chill but
if you're sincere looking at his life
yeah you come to know that he was indeed
a messenger absolute like like like
Jesus at his time if you look at him to
his life you would absolutely say that
he's a messenger because he was the best
human at the best but some people were
spitting on him they were up chasing him
out trying to kill him everyone in the
world is some enemies yeah especially
the good ones like like that Jesus and
like Moses like this
I'm thing happened at about the same
thing has happened to two Moses la salle
horrific absolutely see the same thing
is happening to the last eight I don't
have a problem a lot even when they are
dead yeah when they are dead even
mohamed salah salem is still in his
grave and still people are jealous and
have show some hatred to muhammad
sallallahu slm simply because they can
see the effect of a person in his grave
on living people yeah perhaps you can
say this proudly that the Muslims are
the one who follow the messenger this is
you would never find any people follow
their messenger like the Muslims follow
that's footsteps of prophets allah let's
take a break let's stay will continue
okay we'll be right back neck a lot is
the main tarina one of the beautiful
things about our religion of islam is
the emphasis on direct ritual and prayer
God directly there is no intermediary
the lights will go on after the party
and the party will end it's very simple
and very clear there are no
superstitious rituals no strange
incantations and time is running out and
you might not make it till tomorrow and
this is something that we need to think
about so if you find yourself your Iman
is going down check yourself
and that's that's how a lot of people
are with religion you got some CD or
some music in the car Bobby you head to
50 cent so they're not willing to let go
of some things as no is not working for
them Lady Gaga googoo and all that other
nonsense they know it's not working for
them but they keep hoping that somehow
it will come through for them until they
chew 18 inch bag except we'll see what
happens to Eddie on the Dean show
welcome back to the Dean show we're here
with dr. Mohammed man do and we're
talking about the key to paradise so
continue on shade we just talked about
the negation affirmation and the teacher
who was a teacher like Jesus and Moses
and Abraham and today we need to get to
know the last and final messenger like
you said anyone who comes into this and
approaches it sincerely will see that he
wasn't indeed a messenger alert set by
the crater because the last part on
selected the best human beings to be the
messenger for human beings so Abraham
and Moses and Jesus and Mohammed were
the best at their time well because
mohamed salah salem is the last
messenger so is he's a messenger for all
human beings i want you to see the train
of logic here when we talked about the
key with all these teeth and the first
tooth is seeking knowledge and the most
important knowledge is is about almighty
allah the creator of the heavens and the
earth yeah and then that God has
messengers and we witness that Muhammad
is is a messenger and then we're talking
about now the love of Allah Union the
more you know about a lot of more you
love him and again okay so this is the
third or fourth key here for stews what
comes after that if you love Allah what
is required from you this love should be
translated into action and here if it
doesn't translate into action
it's a fake love it's not a true love if
you want to show that you love someone
right you obey Him yeah you obey Him for
example if your wife asks you to bring
here a green skirt and you travel and
come back with a black scare too
wouldn't you are not pleasing your one
if you want to please her you please
hair with what she wants from you yeah
not let according to you this is exactly
the essence of Robo dia yeah do you want
to worship Allah you worship Allah
according to the way he wants you to
wash or if your mother says the Sun go
get me sleep in the grocery store you
just kiss her say go get it yourself
absolutely so love should be translated
into action and this action is
submission or obedience once you
understood about Allah with all these
attributes beautiful names of Allah span
Amidala you need to translate this into
love so now I love him because of his
mercy I'm ready didn't know what you
want me to dress well how do people love
each other I love him because of his
beauty yes is the most beautiful thing
in this universe huh right anyway so
after that you love him you need to
translate this into obedient into
submission the word obedience at
submission this is the essence or this
is exactly the same meaning of Islam you
become a Muslim you surrender yourself
you submit yourself to the will of Allah
oh Allah what do you want from me
whatever you want from me I am willing
to do i hear mom here out of your
service and I'm your servant tell me
what to do now it's twelve o'clock it's
the time of noon prayer let me get ready
for the prayer this one I mean it's for
some people is hard to get to this day
but we see it every day the man will
come honey however you want honey love
you or the woman say I'll do anything
your hand yes or my boss yes master yes
sir yes yes said and he brings his
coffee sir whatever you hey what can you
do I do here you what can I do if we
should have this dis dis enthusiasm for
the one
who gave us absolutely more than you
have something that's what we do yeah la
Stella wants us to pray at six o'clock
in the morning we pray eight o'clock in
the morn a la semana talents is too fast
in Ramadan we fest in ramada which is
full submission to him because this
submission is a translation of the love
that we have for almighty he doesn't
need these prayers that's what she
doesn't need fact this is for our better
develop this is where this is how to be
good person because when we follow the
commands of allah so allah tala through
the manual that he sent us which is the
holy quran we are doing the things that
teaches how to deal with the quran and
how to deal with the people around you
how to deal with your parents how to
deal with your husband how much money
for example if you die the intended
inheritance should go to that child
whether he is a male or a female how
much money should be given to your
parent after your God how much every
aspect of life every day to the M free
details like the man you get in and you
in the car and okay and tells you how to
manual discs this head if it's without
this manual and you don't have knowledge
you cannot run it yeah so this is
exactly what we need we need this
detailed manual which is the Quran and
the Sunnah of the Prophet salon acela
which he give us the tips how to act in
this life and again and again again so
you see now some few T's are that are in
this too is that open paradise it's
seeking knowledge about Almighty Allah
knowing that there is no deity to be
worshipped followed or obeyed accept
almighty allah knowing that a Lost
Planet Allah had messenger and the last
messenger was Muhammad peace be upon him
you when you know a las konawa to Allah
you need to after that the natural
response when you know all these
qualities about Almighty Allah you love
him and after that this love should be
translated into obedience and this
obedience and this submission is the
essence of this great religion Islam
thank you very much like a la oveja God
willing we'll see you again an initially
on java thank you and if you liked what
the share dr. mundo
had to present here today he has his own
section we've done some more shows with
him at the Dean show calm you could read
a little bit more about him and the key
to paradise first a negation you're not
God I'm not God Jesus is not god jesus
prayed to God Mohammed prayed to God
Moses all the messengers they pray to
God don't be a slave to society into the
fashion and to everything out there be a
slavey committed to pleasing the one who
created you so all these false deities
all these false ideas erase this from
your head from your system ask the one
who created you who gave you life and
give you def to make things clearer to
guide you he's the most loving he's the
most merciful and he knows what's best
for you and he wants what's best for you
come back here every week to the Dean
show we'll see you next time god willing
I said I'm like no speech is better than
to do that was call people to Allah and
to do there were no speeches better you
know nothing is better than that is it
true that if one person I'm the law
giving you an ability to guide so much
for the lost permission the creator's
permission that was better than
everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be given out
giving down and this is something that
we encourage all the MSAs all the dowel
organizations the mustards to get this
we want to print more we give these to
the non mrs. for free for free for free
we want our brothers age
it's cold it's Leigh everybody sleeping
I arise and ask a lot of thinking me
Omar you see all are you know all the
sins I do I turn to you to figure my
sing tomorrow I'm you seen for slave
you're my love alone I'm the one runs
away all the guide me